ties right in with selling something
like digital magazines what are some
good metrics to track oh yeah the ones
we've already touched on so we're
subscription-based service as well so
things that I currently look into and I
look into day and a night is going to be
our acquisitions right so our number
sign ups always looking at cancellations
looking at churn rate which we discussed
earlier and then actually looking at LTV
the reason I look at our lifetime value
and the reason I look at lifetime value
is I want to see the type of customers
that we have coming in expection you
know how long we expect them to be with
us and we actually because I'm you know
Evan said this earlier I'm kind of a
nerd with this stuff I break it out my
channel and source so i want to say if i
have a good amount of people that we
referred are that were sent to us from
facebook i want understand what their
current rate is or what their lifetime
value is those are the things that I
look at constantly non-stop so sorry
that was long-winded but acquisition
cancellations turn rate in lifetime
value are the ones I look at hello and
for me you know with any without knowing
um too much information about the
business i would say again look at what
the sales funnel is so you want people
to buy your digital magazine so where
are they buying it from the bonnet from
your website are they buying it from
your newsletter and if those are the two
primary sources then how do you then get
people to the website into the
newsletter right I think he'd probably
have a lot more success to a newsletter
than just a website because you get to
touch with them every week or every
month or whenever you want to send them
content where with the website you're
hoping that they land on it may only be
a one time thing so are using Facebook
or using YouTube videos are you going to
networking events and if you start to
track this stuff and say hey here's how
many leads I got to my newsletter list
from going to this networking event then
you can say okay this is worth my time
I'm getting an ROI from it and if you
don't track it and you don't know what's
working what's not right maybe you
shouldn't be doing Facebook at all
because it's not getting not the best
sorry I don't want right right I mean
once you're getting some data you can
work okay well how do i improve the
number
how do I make it better how do i
optimize it right if you I test doing
two emails a month and increase the
quality or maybe I work on going to
higher quality or higher and networking
events that are specific to my audience
right once you know where your leads are
coming from it's easier to optimize your
campaign where to spend more time and
potentially dollars too and then what
you might want to cut back and eliminate
from there's the old adage in
advertising that you know fifty percent
of my advertising is being wasted I
didn't know which half yeah people don't
know where they're spending money and i
get like it it's hard for
entrepreneurship you're doing so many
things you know you're trying to run a
quality business and you're you're in
the day to day of running it and you
don't listen to think about all these
things and everybody says okay you got
to do this social media you got to get
on blab now you got to get on youtube
you got to do all these things and and
like when do I actually have time to run
my business right the nice part is a lot
of the tools people are using now like
YouTube blab Facebook free analytics
Google Analytics if no one in the group
is using that yet and you have a website
you should be on that constantly every
day just to see now what's up a traffic
you're getting where people falling off
in the funnel where are my referrals
coming from why getting you know a
thousand some referrals from a certain
domain as opposed to another one so you
just want to make sure you know where
your traffic is coming from how it's
converting and where they're dumping off